I'm joined today by Richard Freeman who
holds the Herbert a Sherman chair and
economics at Harvard University he is
currently serving as faculty co-director
of the labor and work-life program at
the Harvard Law School and is also a
senior research fellow in labor markets
at the London School of Economics a
center for economic performance Richard
it's so great to talk to you we're going
to talk today at least loosely about
what is being described by some as the
decline of men now this is sort of a
hot-button phrase to even use because as
I'm sure you know there's this movement
called the men's rights movement which
is often overlapping with anti feminist
movements sometimes separately sometimes
overlapping and they are making the case
in many ways that we don't need to worry
about gender discrimination against
women anymore because of X Y Z so I want
to be very clear as we jump into our
conversation here much of what you've
written and researched that we're going
to discuss today it's not coming from a
sort of anti feminist perspective is it
no it's coming from facts about changes
in these controlled and let's get into
some of those changes so when we talk
about labor markets let's at least focus
for now on the United States and the way
in which education has a growing role in
the jobs that one is able to obtain it
also relates to regional issues
regarding manufacturing drug abuse I
mean this is a really multifaceted thing
give us the sort of overview about how
men are suffering in the labor market in
some ways well it's some groups of men
it's not all men right of course and
what was happened has been men dominated
a set of jobs which at one point were
paying good wages and we're valuable
to prevent our families and to live a
reasonably good life and those jobs lots
of which are associated with
manufacturing have has declined over
time and they decline pretty pretty
sharply and the kind of men who were
able to make good lives for themselves
and their families through those con
jobs tended to be less less educated men
I think of these as being jobs where
manual skills were needed and we now
have a foreign competition with low-wage
manual workers and we have lots of
automation and robotics
so these men have a problem in the job
market this is very interesting because
you know I've commented that during the
presidential campaign neither Donald
Trump nor Hillary Clinton talked about
sort of reality of technological
automation and the replacement of jobs
by robots and artificial intelligence
you're pointing out that there's
actually going to be a sort of
disproportionate impact on jobs
overwhelmingly disproportionately held
by men by that technological automation
because of the nature of those jobs am i
understanding that correctly well to mix
that it's obviously the nature of the
jobs and it's also about the education
and other sort of training or attributes
that men bring to the jobs one of the
things that in the job market is
interpersonal jobs of interpersonal
skills and have done better and then
then jobs let's say take muscle and and
perseverance or whatever and women tend
to be more depth at interpersonal skills
and when you say that Richard because I
know that you know a lot of what we're
talking about here is really going to
rile people up for different reasons and
in different ways you're not necessarily
suggesting that there's some sort of
genetic or
geological explanation per se as to why
women in our society may be more adept
at those jobs does it go to
everything from socialization culture
education etc is it more of a nurture
versus nature explanation well we don't
know how much is nurture and how much is
nature but certainly for the generations
women with women have have been it more
in the interpersonal jobs they don't
have the size and the muscles of men so
there's been a division of labor that
you know does come with us as human
beings and if one part of that division
of labor where the men have specialized
um it's it's easier to automate bring
robots in and also leave the workers
overseas able to do that as well when we
look at the know gonna get action nature
versus nurture when we look at the next
generation of workers so to speak and we
sort of evaluate the demographics
including the gender demographics of who
is currently in college does that
suggest that this is going to be a
situation that improves or worsens for
men over time
oh we mean the fact is that women make
up a majority of the students in
universities and the men make up a
majority of people who drop out of high
school or a little further than high
school so that and that imbalance we
women are doing more to higher education
that the men occurs in both almost every
country in the world at this point so
there's been a real shift at one point
men dominated universities now women are
the majority and and I don't see what's
going to change that in the
in the future and so that mean that does
put men and a disadvantage in many jobs
there's sort of social impact to this as
well aren't there I was recently reading
that for whatever reason right and we
could we could talk in this direction if
you think it's valuable for whatever
reason in the United States currently
overall on balance doesn't apply to
every woman but generally speaking
heterosexual women who are interested in
being in a relationship with another man
generally they don't want to be with a
man that they perceive as intellectually
inferior to them do you agree with that
number one and number two how is that
going to sort of create a social
dynamics problem going forward okay what
is one part of the American population
that has this imbalance in much greater
than other parts and so we can learn and
see what happened to that part
that's our black community the black
women have gotten much more education
and then black men on average and we
know that black men have had all kinds
of problems from you know jail prison
for for crimes and for discrimination
reasons as well think you probably are
overly charged with crimes and overly
keen on but that that is meant that
nevah community women have had a long
history of dealing and looking for mates
with men who are less adept in the in
education and in the job market than
them and what will be the longer-term
impact of that if this trend were to
continue I mean eventually or we would
what possible ways could this go well I
mean the array as a man I would not like
to see him talk his more were men you
know
fall into a a marginal position society
because they are they can't adapt to
don't adopt their skills um and they're
able to you know compete in job markets
and compete for mates in the marriage
market um generally what happens in the
labor market is with some kinds of
attributes or skills or get to be lose
their value the people do shift it takes
a while but once you learn that gee you
better be literate if you're going to
succeed people gain literacy when we
were a foreign country literacy would
not be as high as when we're at a more
urban country so I assume so they hope
that there will will be adjustments and
that ultimately will resolve any
problems we ask let's pick up our
conversation there with Richard Freeman
from the from Harvard University as well
as Harvard Law School we will continue
our conversation with him on tomorrow's
program
we're continuing our conversation today
with Richard Freeman who holds the
Herbert a Sherman chair in economics at
Harvard University currently serving as
faculty co-director of the labor and
work-life program at the Harvard Law
School also a senior research fellow in
labor markets at the London School of
Economics center for economic
performance so on the first part of the
interview Richard we spoke a lot about
the ways in which some of the shifting
dynamics in the American labor market
education etc are are exposing a sort of
decline of men as you've outlined let's
now go through a few other interesting
sort of scenarios and and corollary
discussions there will no doubt be some
people in our audience who will have
heard our first part of the conversation
I'll say David women are still in total
discriminated against in the labor
market although 77 cents on the dollar
is not an accurate figure 90 to 91 cents
on the dollar in terms of doing the same
work as men does seem to be a pretty
accurate assessment Richard Freeman is
talking about a problem that is not
really a problem because it ignores the
problem of gender discrimination what
would you say to that well knows a
problem for former men with less
education and and let's say not very
good interpersonal skills and in there's
a problem for women they who do face
more explicit or implicit forms of
discrimination and what one way of
thinking about it is is that the men men
at the top you know at all is the CEOs
of predominantly men the presidents of
the countries that still did all men and
the Congress's study and leadership
things at the top men do well but then
the jails are filled with men too and so
then at the bottom do more probably
so it's more subtle than a gender issue
and I I mean I know people and I know
it's data yes women particularly the top
face all kinds of problems and then we
know many of them at the bottom of these
skill distribution face problems too
there are different problems but they're
connected with gender but they're not
gender caused problems in a deeper sense
are there some aspects of what we've
been discussing that might relate to the
success of the Trump brand of right-wing
populism that has appealed to men that
may be in the categories that you're
talking about
oh that's very possible I'm not an
expert on you know why get some groups
voted for for Trump but certainly there
were a lot of people and these would be
primarily on blue-collar less educated
people who were told that the economy
was going great guns and it was not to
them and disproportionately for men but
also even for that for women with less
education and Oh blue-collar jobs and
it's still not going well for many of
these these people so I think if
anything generated that movement of this
these type of people toward mr. Trump as
opposed to the promised mrs. Clinton it
was that the Washington establishment
was was not telling the truth about
their problems and they were pushing it
under rugs and denying them and that
came back and did the folks in
Washington I'm trying to imagine Richard
if rich if Hillary Clinton had said
something along the lines of basically
just outlining what you and I have been
talking about right which is that if you
are a less educated man
could be could be a white man in the
United States uh that there is this
dynamic that is going on and this is
something that she could have
potentially campaigned on in some way I
wonder what the net impact of that would
have been because no doubt she might
have been able to appeal to some of the
men that ended up voting for Donald
Trump because of the sort of right-wing
populism that he espoused but at the
same time it might have it might have
made female voters uh maybe resent that
she was talking about that I mean I I
don't know if you have any thoughts
about the political implications of that
but it seems like it could have been
both potentially beneficial but
simultaneously risky drive our thinking
with bothered females who would like to
have male mates who have good jobs that
are you know and that they do better in
the in the education system um I think
that it was really a question of the
highly educated elites in the country
versus people that will be having
troubles adjusting to the changes in our
economy and sorry I don't see I don't
see the women as saying no you shouldn't
try to help me the you know the men do
better
no and I'm not suggesting that but more
the idea that hey you know we should
really be focused particularly if you're
looking at the the first major
democratic or Republican presidential
nominee who's a woman to go out there
and hear her talking about the decline
of men it may not have been the best
optics right I mean I'm sure you agree
with that I'm not sure because I don't
think when we have to pose it so much in
gender that's it's really the working
people of the country who are not
college educated and you could have
posed this as an issue for people to
whom the economic changes are our time
from trade to the automation where we're
leaving behind and then dangering
they're there they're there
your work lives or their current work
lives you couldn't post it in a way I
think that would have cut across gender
issues and in fact that it is
disproportionately men all that some
problems we all want to reduce crime and
that crime disproportionately affects
some groups that other groups but this
against crime role against crime is this
has there been any other point in human
history where a problem with these
dynamics has surfaced because I'm
thinking when humans were closer to
being in a state of nature and then
during the hunter-gatherer phase and
even in early agriculture it was sort of
pretty clear like you you need some
people to be able to lift heavy things
and hunt etc and it was pretty clear who
was going to be doing those tasks and
then even with the Industrial Revolution
you still saw that there were that there
was sort of a pretty clear set of jobs
where it was men who were going to be
doing them is there another phase or
place in human history where we saw an
issue with similar dynamics I don't know
I don't think so because if you think
the period of time when we were advocate
taykitty America we were primarily after
a cultural society and you farm work was
divided up the men would do much of a
heavy farm work and their women would
basically be running a household
production system and doing some of the
lighter the lighter welcome there was
place for both people it's kind of a bit
weird there that we did don't count in
our national income what was being done
in the household but there were two
parts to that to that equation now it's
I think it is very unique now we've been
speaking with Richard Freeman he holds
the herbert ashram and chair in
economics at Harvard University
currently serving as faculty co-director
of the labor and work-life program
the Harvard Law School Richard thanks so
much for talking to us about this today
okay my pleasure bye-bye